I do have big news out of Washington
tonight where the Attorney General
Merrick Garland says the special counsel
investigating Joe Biden's alleged
mishandling of classified information
well they have completed their work and
the White House is now reviewing the
report to see if it wants to exert
executive privilege over any part of
that and once that process is done the
report will be released to Congress and
to We the People the public we are
hearing that could happen by the end of
the week now apparently that is
something that team Biden is very afraid
of axio reporting that Biden's AIDS
believe the report will include
embarrassing details and photos and be
quote politically damaging now could the
evidence be more damning than what we
already have seen you might remember
this photo there you go the beautiful
Corvette and the Glock garage that never
opens anyway showing those documents
there top secret documents in Joey's
garage next to his prize Corvette as a
sitting president President Biden is
unlikely to face any criminal charges as
a matter of fact he won't but if the
photos in that report what if they look
a lot like the photos that we were shown
over and over again from the maral Lago
raid and I guess the only real Damage
Done is going to be the exposure of Joe
Biden's weaponized justice department
huh that wouldn't be good here with
reaction Fox News legal analyst Greg
Jarrett um I think if they're so afraid
of the photos I I think probably the
main reason is the fact that it will
expose a two-tier justice system a
weaponized and politicized uh doj of Joe
Biden they protected him the photos look
just like Mara Lago what is that going
to show
people well you know I would say credit
is
deserving of the whistleblowers I mean
they're the ones who told us that the
doj has been running a protection record
for Joe Biden for years remember
investigators were banned from asking
about Joe's involvement in his son's
influence pedaling schemes uh despite
evidence of complicity uh so Sean did
anybody really expect that Joe's
document Scandal would be treated any
differently I think the fix was in from
the beginning Trump gets charged Biden
doesn't even though and this is
important Joe has no defense under the
federal records act Trump does because
some of the records came from Biden's
time as a Senator not president and
under the records act a former president
can have custody and control over such
documents not a senator uh indeed that
was the opinion of the Department of
Justice for two long decades they argued
in the famous Bill Clinton case uh that
you know a former president can keep
whatever he wants including classified
documents a federal judge agreed
suddenly Trump comes along and the doj
throws that policy out the window they
indict Trump on top of it they charge it
with it obstruction for doing exactly
what Bill Clinton did Clinton resisted
the proper legal remedy here was for
merri Garland to file a civil action not
criminal uh which is under the act and
it's the governing Authority that's how
the Clinton case was handled let a judge
decide who gets what instead they
criminalized it because it's Donald
Trump another example of how the doj has
a two- tiered system of
justice yeah you know Alex Baron had a
pretty good name for it he called it
lawfare in a column that he wrote and
that is we're weaponizing and
criminalizing political differences just
a different way to say it but a pretty
uh astute analysis all right Greg Jared
thank you for that update we appreciate
it hey Sean Hannity here hey click here
to subscribe to Fox News YouTube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis you will not
get it anywhere
else